This idea that Black people have to earn their way out of racism
is completely backwards
so I understand you as saying that if
as a result of the actions of some people
a group has acquired the reputation for harming other people
then the negative attitudes and treatment the entire group receives
is understandable and justified
and what's more
if that group wants those negative attitudes and treatments to change
they have to do better
I highly suggest that you reexamine this belief
in light of the fact that
at the point of which Europeans label Black people Black
and by extension
label themselves ✉️
they are the ones who proceeded to loot
kill and grape their way around 84% of the world for centuries
because I don't think you feel that it would justify
if people of the global majority were to treat ✉️ people
the way that ✉️ people have treated Black people
and maybe consider yourself lucky that we don't now
with respect to these Black crime rates that people like you so love to inflate
if racism were to cease to exist today
those crime rates would automatically and instantly drop
because we wouldn't have innocent Black people
being arrested and incarcerated for nothing
and we wouldn't have Black people being arrested and incarcerated
for infractions that ✉️ people get away with all the time
but also if you systematically oppress a group of people for centuries
it will create negative behaviors
and it shows the infinite grace of Black people
that it hasn't created more
and what's more
the people that it harms the most are Black people themselves
so if you want these crime rates to drop
it is racism that has to cease to exist first